Hi everybody.
I'm Rachel Amera.
I'm based here in San Francisco.
I'm really excited to be hosting our speaker today.
Carter cast a little bit about Carter.
He's here to talk about his book,
the right and wrong stuff.
And Carter just came in from Chicago.
I,
he is a professor at Northwestern university in the Kellogg School of
Management.
He is a active teacher in the entrepreneurship and business school courses
there,
which is great.
He's also an established business veteran and venture capitalists.
So,
uh,
Carter started his career at Pepsico and derailed,
so we're going to hear more about that.
I think today.
I love that word derailed and landed on his feet obviously.
He also,
uh,
was the chief marketing officer,
founder of uh,
Blue Nile.
So if you actually remember that company from the days of the heyday,
uh,
I do.
Then he was one of those integrity people from there and work with Doubleclick
as they were,
uh,
active with Blue Nile and also worked as the CEO,
well@theceoofwalmart.com.
So a lot of experience.
We're super excited to hear about what he's going to share today about careers
and derailing and getting back on track.
So please welcome Carter cast.
Thank you.
One of the questions I get is why would you write a book about failure?
Uh,
so let me tell you what peaked my interest in this topic was I had a,
uh,
I lost touch with an old boss and he was super fancy,
you know,
the right schools and super smart and I lost touch with them.
And about 10 years after,
uh,
the last time we met,
I called him up and I asked him,
you know,
how's,
how's your wife?
How's your kids?
And then I said,
how's your career?
You know,
what are you doing?
And there was this disappointment in his voice when he talked about his career
and he hadn't reached the expected level of achievement that I thought he would
and that probably other people thought too.
So we hung up the phone and I literally wrote on a sticky note,
what impedes the progress of talented people?
And I stuck it on my wall at Northwestern and then I decided it was such a,
it's sort of a provocative question for me that I asked the dean of the business
school if I could take a quarter off from teaching and just research and see are
there certain behavioral traits or skill gaps,
certain themes that account for people that are good,
not achieving their expected level of development.
And so what I found is there are,
and then I flipped the topic on its head and I looked at what do high performers
that don't derail,
what do they've got,
what's the right stuff?
And so one of the major ways I did this,
but I interviewed a hundred people that got fired or demoted.
I talked to a lot of coaches,
HR,
vps,
executive recruiters,
Ceos.
But I also mind three 60 a research databases.
So I looked at three like thousands and thousands of three sixties and teased
out the difference between people in the top 10% you know,
like people that were at the top 10% and managerial effectiveness.
What was their competency profile set versus people that were rated in the top
and the bottom core tile.
And I found that there's these very specific competencies they have.
What's Kinda cool is it's not like a good at everything.
There's only a couple of things that these people are good at,
but they're good at these things.
Consistency consistently.
I don't get into those.
Okay,
so what I thought we do here is I will go on and talk for about 30 minutes and
I'm going to go over these five reasons.
I found that people run into trouble and then we'll take a break and have
questions and then I'll far last 10 or 15 minutes,
I'll talk about the wrong,
the right stuff.
What people that do well,
what these competencies are.
Okay.
So we'll get to look at both sides of the question.
We're going to look at why do talented people derail,
but also what do high performers do?
Very specifically,
that's different.
So first of all,
this is not a niche topic.
Half to two thirds of us will have a derailment event.
Either we'll get demoted or fired.
I did.
So I'll talk about that very honestly.
Um,
let me talk about definitions.
When I talk about derailment,
I'm talking about people who didn't reach the expected level of achievement by
the HR Department or by their boss.
So they're not people.
By the way,
this is not a personal derailment.
I did not look in this Dataset at people that derailed because they loved living
in boulder and they wanted to stay in boulder so they didn't take a move or they
are triathletes and they wanted to work out and they'll know wanting to work 20
hours a week or they had to take care of their kids and they worked three days a
week.
If they,
if they made personal decisions that accounted for a quote unquote derailment,
that was their decision.
I'm looking here at people that wanted the brass ring and we're working their
tail off and didn't get it.
What happens?
Okay.
The second caveat to this is I found in looking at all this research for three
years,
that organizations are complicit.
They move people too quickly,
they ignore bad behavior.
If the person's hitting their numbers and they don't require superiors to
develop subordinates like they used to,
you know,
you could say maybe part of that's the GIG economy.
But the problem is as a result employees,
us,
we aren't getting the feedback we need in most organizations.
So I think it's wonderful that you do events like this so you can get,
you can hear from a wide variety of people.
So here are the five reasons I found over and over and over in the research to
make this more palatable and a little less sort of like jarring.
Like you,
you know,
instead of saying,
oh I suffer from it,
or personal,
you know,
issues,
you could say,
I have a little bit of captain fantastic in me.
So I created these archetypes to make the topic less,
you know,
kind of less difficult.
So here's the first reason.
This is captain fantastic.
This is the fellow who bruises you on his quest for the holy grail of the corner
office.
He's ego driven,
he's dismissive,
he's got poor listening skills.
I me,
mine is his mantra and we've all experienced him and he usually does well
because he's a self promoter that then he hits a wall at a certain point and
because he gets in a complex assignment where he needs the enlistment of other
people and they don't want to work with them.
And eventually you'll see that he was moved to special projects.
And then from there,
six weeks later,
he's no longer in the building.
We know this guy.
So he has a relational issues,
overly ambitious,
driven by ego.
Now let's say you're not this person,
there's another aspect of this interpersonal issues I want want you to,
maybe you should pay attention to.
So this woman named Karen Horne,
I was a clinical psychiatrist in the forties and fifties and she did a lot of
work with people that have everyday neuroses.
She found that we have three tendencies under pressure.
We do three things that self sabotage.
She said,
we either move away from people when times are difficult.
We,
um,
we distance ourselves were skeptics were cautious,
we move against,
people were combative or we moved towards people by being ingratiating.
So that's Karen Horne.
I,
so Robert and Joyce Hogan took her work and develop the Hogan Development
System,
which is a very powerful tool that looks at a whole variety of things from goals
to potential to derailment propensities.
And they took her work and they found these 11 specific behavioral traits that
happen to all of us under pressure.
We do one of 11 things.
We will you see that first block,
excitable skeptic cautious.
That is the moving away from that Karen Horne I found then that next block is
the moving against by being mischievous or arrogant or melodramatic.
And then the last block is moving towards by being ingratiating.
All of us do at least one of these things.
I've taken this test,
I had to,
my sister's taking it,
she had a couple,
we created this Zell fellows,
um,
Sam Zell.
We created a program at Kellogg and we take high potential entrepreneurs and we
put them in this bootcamp program called Zelle scholars.
And we make all of the Zell scholars take this and all of them have some of
these tendencies cause you know we're human.
We're going to have some,
the question is do you understand your own so that they don't hurt you?
So there is a recent Harvard business review article two weeks ago,
She did this Meta analysis on self awareness.
You ought to get,
it's a great article.
And,
and she said there's two types of self awareness,
internal self awareness.
Do we understand ourselves to understand our motives and our weaknesses and our
strengths,
our vulnerabilities and there's external self awareness.
Do we understand how we're viewed by other people?
And she said that 10 to 15% of us have self awareness,
10 to 15% of us,
85 to 90% of US lack self awareness.
So the Hogan is a great way to understand where you might have some of these
interpersonal areas that are holding you back.
Here's a guy right about this time.
This guy derailed.
This is me,
right about 29 or 30 and I was called into my bosses office during my annual
performance review.
He told me I was insubordinate,
I was at Frito Lay,
I was a senior marketing manager.
He said,
you're insubordinate,
you don't take my direction.
Well you're a calcitrant.
I had to look that up.
I know wasn't quite sure what that meant and I want you off my team.
And I said,
Mike,
I'll call him Mike because that was his name.
are you firing me?
And he said,
not technically,
but good luck finding somebody who wants you in their group.
And so I took two weeks off and I talked to my dad.
I said,
Dad,
what do I do?
You know,
can you believe this guy?
And he said,
well your mother and I are amaze,
you've made it seven years in a corporation.
So he wasn't much help.
So I decided to go back to Frito lay cause I didn't want to end on that kind of
a note.
And I came back and found that I had this reputation for being difficult to
manage.
And I finally found this guy that would take me in his group.
He's a Canadian,
he just moved from Canada.
So he didn't know my reputation and he took me in and he helped me.
But what happened was I took this Hogan and I had these two traits that if I
would've known about and would have been able to manage more effectively,
I probably wouldn't have run into this trouble with my boss.
This trade of leisurely is,
it's a weird word,
leisurely.
It's basically when the heavy hand of authority pushes on you,
you tend to sort of blow that,
blow it off.
You know,
I may or I may not follow the direction that my bosses suggesting
and mischievous and my case,
which is,
you know,
let's throw a grenade in this meeting just to liven it up,
you know?
And so these traits,
I had served me poorly with a,
uh,
a bureaucratic system and a heavy handed boss.
And I derailed and,
and my point in sharing this story with you is,
if I would have understood this about myself,
I think I could have rained this in once I understood this about myself,
that trait,
those traits,
I still have them.
I still have the tendency but they don't come out to play as much because I'm
aware of them and I'm aware of certain situations that stoke them,
so that is the first one,
captain.
Fantastic.
Even if you aren't that cat that's this arrogant and ego driven,
you still probably have one of those 11 Hogan traits that you've got to watch
out for,
so there's a good book called why CEOs fail
by dot.
Lich and Kero,
c a I,
r o and in that they take the 11 Hogan traits and they list specific questions
you can ask yourself to see if you have any of them and you will,
so it's the devil you know here.
Second reason people fail that first one by the way,
is more in men and it's often as you get to be higher and higher level,
you stop listening to people because you think you have the answers and you
start thinking,
you start thinking that you know it and you don't seek feedback from the front
line who always have the answers because they're closest to the customer.
The second one is the Solo Flyer.
This happens usually pretty early in careers.
What happens is you get a strong individual contributor,
they get promoted and they still try to do all the work themselves,
so they micromanage.
They usually fail to develop their team.
They tat they hand out tasks but they don't develop the people.
Lominger limited is a company that does talent management Lominger.
They were just bought by Korn ferry recently.
Lameer looks at 67 managerial competencies.
It's a lot.
You know most companies looking at about 10 they have 10 I don't know how many
Google has,
but 67 of 67 in terms of managerial effectiveness developing others.
It's the lowest rated trait by managers.
So the chances are pretty good that you know you aren't going to get ma,
you aren't going to be developed well and so you have to do it yourself.
The other thing that was interesting and looking at this cause you get the micro
managing,
you have to learn to let go.
Actually Linda Hill,
this professor at Harvard said,
getting promoted into management from being an individual contributor is
literally a transformation of identity.
We have to learn from to go from doing to enabling and it's hard when you're
good at doing,
it's hard to let go of the doing.
So this third one though was interesting to me.
Linda Hill also found,
she wrote this book called becoming a manager.
She followed 20 managers around who just got promoted and she saw like
ethnographic research kind of followed him around,
took notes like Jane Goodall,
dead in gorillas and the mess,
you know,
watching.
And she said that one of the things managers did poorly was they didn't realize
that it's one thing for me to manage you and it's one thing for me,
another thing for me to manage our,
this team here,
but at least half my time as a manager should be enabling this team to be
effective by building bridges to other functions where we have dependencies and
so that she caused that managing context.
Are you managing the context surrounding your team?
Are you building bridges?
So I asked people if you list your key initiatives that you're working on and
you knew listed next to them where you have the people that you have
dependencies on and then you list next to them,
what's your contact strategy with those people?
Are you taking them to lunch?
Are you taking them to coffee?
When's the last time you interacted with them?
You've got to be managing the context because obviously you know business is a
team sport,
so we have all these dependencies crossfunctionally that we rely on.
Solo Flyer doesn't understand that yet.
So the third reason for derailment is version 1.0 and this one sort of
terrifying.
This happens a lot mid career.
You get these,
you get complacent in your job,
you're good at your job and you kind of dial down your curiosity and you don't
stay up to speed on cryptocurrency and you aren't quite sure how AI might apply
to your customer service business.
You don't understand what audible is doing to disrupt the subscription model.
You know,
to disrupt the publishing model,
you just don't stay current and you become this fossilized dinosaur guy that's
version 1.0 so he suffers from changing circumstances,
lack of adaptability a lot of times to technological change,
but sometimes it's another kind of change.
He's not adaptable to getting a new boss.
When I derailed,
I was doing really well with my old boss and he was a very empowering boss.
When I got the new boss who was more participative,
I had organ rejection and I lost.
He didn't lose.
I lost.
So that's the first one.
Then the other one is just making sure you stay curious.
So I ask people that might suffer from this.
How well are you honing your discovery skills?
Are you this based on work from Clayton Christianson of Harvard,
he looked at executives that have either delivery skills.
He found the kind of neatly breakout into delivery skills and discovery skills.
Delivery skills are like analyzing,
um,
executing,
communicating,
aligning and discovery skills or these five.
So how well are he also found that people that are innovative have a ratio of
six to one on questions asked to statements made,
so they ask a lot of questions,
a lot of what if and how might we questions.
They also observe customers.
They go out in the field,
they go out in the market and they watch customers interact with the product to
understand what problems are they facing,
what kind of work arounds are they doing,
how can they improve the product?
One time I spent some time,
I take,
I teach this class that's all about this stuff called new venture discovery at
Kellogg.
You might know the shoe.
All birds that came out of my class,
that was a student in my class that invented this shoe.
In our class,
we build prototypes.
We go out in the market.
We test these rough prototypes,
digital prototypes.
Then we build,
you know,
physical prototypes,
kind of Ido,
ask research.
Tim Brown developed all birds doing a lot of this observational research.
One time I was with this guy who was the product manager on an adult diaper
brand.
We are spending doing some research with with him.
And I said,
well,
what's it like to,
how long have you been on the business?
He said,
for years.
I said,
what's it like to wear the diapers?
And he said,
well,
I'm not incontinent.
And I said,
I know,
but like if you to put on the diapers and the UPN them,
what's it like when you walk around with that on?
And he said,
well I've never done that.
And I said,
how do you understand what your customer is going through if you're not wearing
the product?
So you know,
be the discovery.
Research is being out in the shoes of the customer and seeing what they
experience.
It's also experimenting.
I know Google is very good at this and Amazon is very good at this.
Bayzos once said,
I haven't failed.
I've just found a thousand things that don't work.
You know,
this is ab testing.
This is building rough prototypes and getting him out in the hands of customers
and watching them interact with them.
Experimenting also another aspect of discovery skills.
That version 1.0 could use is networking.
Really establishing a strong set of relationships with people that have a
diverse backgrounds that can help you problem solve.
So really working on your networking skills is very important.
And then the big kind of the Mac daddy of them all is associational thinking.
Your ability to synthesize diverse inputs.
So this is,
you know the example people give is like a George Ms Straw walking his sheep dog
in the Alps and then he comes home and he picks the burrs out of the dog and he
comes up with
velcro.
Yeah,
associational thinking.
Uh,
Einstein said creativity is nothing more than common.
A tutorial play.
So version 1.0 lacks this discovery orientation and it's hurting his
effectiveness.
The fourth reason I found that people derail is,
is this archetype is the one trick pony.
This is someone who's very competent at one thing,
but they haven't broadened.
So maybe it's a controller who would love to be the CFO,
but she knows accounting.
She's,
she got us off quickbooks and our startup,
she's great with the audits,
but she doesn't understand.
She doesn't have any exposure to forecasting or to capital asset management to
long range strategic planning.
And she's not going to get the CFO job that she'd like because she hasn't
broadened enough.
So this is a derailer that hits us a lot of times mid career too.
We've gone narrowly up a path,
which is smart because we've become an expert,
but at some point we have to start broadening our skillset and our experience
that if we want to be able to keep rising up through the organization,
this person suffers from over dependence on one skill.
So there's sort of lopsided and they haven't broadened their skillset.
They also may have a key skill deficiency in an area that's really important to
the business.
So for example,
if you're at
electronic arts,
it's a local business.
If you're an ea like I was,
what do,
yeah.
Where,
where,
what do you have to know?
Even no matter what department you're in,
you have to know what something about what you have to understand game play.
You have to understand,
um,
how a great game is made,
how you can make a game addictive.
And 50 strokes is what they say at ea.
If you're at Frito lay,
you have to understand sales and distribution because that company is built on
25,000 route salespeople putting the product everywhere you've got,
understand that she has,
could have a key skill deficiency in an area that's important to business and
she doesn't have,
she hasn't had enough experiences that give her the ability to see the big
picture and solve complex problems by understanding the role of different
functions play in an organization.
So let's say I had this one trick pony in my group and I'm at Walmart
and this is the feedback she's gotten and she's,
I'm mentoring her.
I might do something like this now,
this is my only wonky slide,
so forgive me.
It's my one business wonky slide.
So let's look at this.
I might say Gail,
let's say her name is Gail Gail.
Let's lay out the critical path of Walmart.
What's the critical path?
The critical path are the key activities in any company that add value to the
customer.
Okay.
What are the key activities at Walmart?
We would write down sourcing,
merchandising,
ops and store operations.
Then we would say within those areas,
what are the critical things we do that we gotta be good at to win?
And we would write down supplier negotiation cause you got under negotiate for
Edlp,
every day,
low price assortment planning.
Good,
better,
best for the assortment,
right?
Making sure you're in stock on the products under logistics,
inbound and outbound warehouse management.
What's the inventory software that allows the product to,
can flow in and out of these big warehouses and inside the store,
two critical areas are planograms,
merchandising,
Action Alley,
and managing the 700 people that are inside of a supercenter.
So those might be six of the things we write down that are critical path
activities at Walmart.
And I said,
Gail,
do you understand these activities?
No.
You know,
let's say I'm,
she's a controller who wants to become the CFO.
I'd say,
well,
how about we set up time
a day a day with somebody who's an expert in each one of these places in the
company.
They'd love to have you tag along and watched them for a day.
So in the next two months,
we're going to take six days in the next two months for you to get exposure with
a store manager on how they manage the Labor,
understanding the planigram philosophy around how we merchandise inside of a
store,
get inside of a warehouse and understand inventory,
controls and management.
I guarantee you after she has those experiences,
there's nobody that's going to say she's,
she's non strategic because she's going to understand the company and the
critical path of activities that create value to the customer.
So I would,
I would ask you guys,
you know,
the rhetorical question,
what are the critical path activities at Google and do you understand them
regardless of what function you're in,
whether you're an engineer,
you're in sales,
sales and marketing,
do you understand the key activities that Google does to create differentiation
in the market?
And if you don't talk to people who have a nice purview,
relist those key activities down and just start familiarizing yourself with
those areas that are outside of your function so you broaden your view on the
business.
This is a very,
very solvable derailment area.
Captain.
Fantastic is tougher because that's a behavioral issue,
right?
That person is going to probably have to have a two by four upside the head
before he realizes that his ego run a mock is not going to serve them well.
This one you can fix,
so the last one and then we'll take a little break and we'll talk about some of
these.
This is the whirling dervish.
This person doesn't deliver on promises.
Usually it's a very creatively minded person whose are bigger than their
stomach.
They take on too much.
They usually have poor organizational skills.
They don't have a system.
They should probably re David Allen's book getting things done.
They have trouble prioritizing what are the key activities that I should really
focus on that move the needle,
the high leverage activities and which are the ones I can blow off because we
can never get all our stuff done,
so they need to prioritize their a bs and cs and hit the A's hard.
Probably ignore the seas.
They probably don't understand process management.
If you ask them to look at their projects and do a Gantt chart on them,
they probably wouldn't be able to go cradle the grave what the key activities
are and how long they take.
So they might say to the boss,
yeah,
I can get that done by June.
No,
no,
no.
F we're not going to get FDA approval on the product til May.
Then we've got an order packaging film.
We've got to move the product and the supply chain.
By the time it goes on shelf,
it's going to be December,
not June.
They don't understand the critical path
and often they're pleasers who can't say no,
and this is one of my behavior.
This is another one of my derailment areas is I overextend by saying yes to too
many things.
So a good trick there is,
first of all,
I love the book the power of a positive no,
that's by a guy named William Ury who wrote getting to yes,
the book on negotiations.
He's a Harvard professor.
He says in the power of a positive note.
Remember when you say no to something you're saying yes to something else that's
important to you.
So I might be saying yes to my kids dinner with my kids and my wife.
I might be saying yes to a workout for my stiff neck.
So that's one thing I always remember as a reformed pleaser.
Another one is Adam Grant talks about this in his book,
give and take.
He talks about the five minute favor.
Maybe you say no,
but you spiff them,
you help somebody out.
So it's not a cold,
harsh,
no.
I'll give an example of this.
I was just asked to go to Seattle to give a presentation to high potential
Kellogg prospects.
And I'm in the middle of this book tour and I'm teaching two classes and I'm a
venture capitalist.
I don't have time.
I didn't have time,
but I told the director of admissions,
I can't go to,
I can't fly out to Seattle from Chicago,
but if you tell me the three or four or five people that you meet there that are
entrepreneurial,
I'll call them and I'll try to convince them to come to Kellogg.
So instead of a two day commitment,
I turned it into a three or four hour commitment.
So that's like a five minute favor.
So
these are
the five captain.
Fantastic,
ego-driven doesn't listen.
You know what Saint Francis of Assisi said,
seek to understand before being understood.
It doesn't get that interpersonal issues.
But remember you might not be a captain.
Fantastic.
And you might still have one of those derailment traits that Hogan has in those
11 descriptors.
Does it build and lead teams?
That's often earlier in a career,
super good individual contributor that gets a team and still tries to do the
work themselves.
Version 1.0 which is that a problem with adaptability and often a problem with
learning stick.
Got It.
I doubt that's going to affect you guys cause you're probably very curious.
But staying curious and not getting set in your ways is a,
is a definitely a derail a Drell for most people being narrow.
That one trick pony going up in a vertical in a vertical way instead of taking
lateral moves to get more experienced or raising your hand to be on a task force
to gain your exposure to other areas.
And then the whirling dervish which has trouble delivering on promises because
they overextend.
So maybe we stop there.
These are the five things I found in three years of research that cause talented
people to derail.
Great.
So we're going to pause here for questions.
I know,
uh,
we'll take some questions and I'll let you speak in the mic.
Anyone have a question?
Top of mind.
Hi and thanks for being here.
Of the five common reasons for derailment.
What's the distribution like?
Which ones are more common than others in the research that you see?
Very good.
Two of them affect more people then the other three and they are version 1.0 I
think that with the rate of change that we live in,
if you don't,
if you know,
you shut your eyes,
you know,
things change.
It's staying curious.
Um,
learning agility,
learning agility is,
you know,
are you open minded,
are you reflective after you do something to reflect on how it went?
Do you seek feedback constantly on a regular basis?
Do you have those discovery skills to go out in the market and watch your
customer and,
and,
and talk to your suppliers?
Look at the competition.
So that is the,
that is the probably the single biggest along with interpersonal issues that are
usually driven by lack of empathy and lack of understanding the other person's
perspective.
Now here's a caveat on my website.
I built this website and I put my derailment assessment on it.
So if you go on Carter,
cast.com I think it's back slash resources.
You'll see this assessment you can take to see which of these five you might
suffer from.
The number one self reported reason.
Everyone is saying they feel like a wheel.
Not everyone.
There's a lot of people saying they feel like a whirling dervish.
So my theory on that is
with,
so we're being delusional with tweets and texts and emails and social media
messages.
I think everyone just feels like a whirling dervish right now period.
So that is the self reported but the research and it was a really rigorous,
it's those two I mentioned.
Oh hold on one.
Let me get,
let me get you the mic.
Okay.
Okay,
thanks.
Adequate followup on that,
which is how much of them are unique to a particular archetype versus a mix of a
few?
Cause I see bits of myself and a few of them.
Yes.
That's a really good question.
A lot of times different stages of your career,
your flirt with different ones of these.
So I was told I was a one trick pony when I didn't understand pepsico very well
and they said,
you know,
you're,
you're not strategic,
you're good at getting things done,
but you don't really have a good sense of strategy.
Well I was 30 you know,
I was going to learn that over time.
So I that the captain fantastic is a tendency I have with,
with bosses that are micromanage me.
That's very bad that I learned about mid career.
I'm worried now about version 1.0 because of the rate of change in technology
and I worry about whirling dervish now because I'm overextended.
So I think it's natural to feel like there's bits and pieces of these in the
book I actually have,
I spend probably this is more like a field guide.
I lay out the derailer and then I spend a lot of time on remedies.
So you'll find different pieces of derailleurs that affect you and you'll find
certain remedies that might help you.
But I think it's natural to feel like you have pieces of different ones of them.
Especially if you look over time,
you might've felt like earlier on you you're a solo flyer,
but then you became a good manager and then another one old kind of bother you.
It will at a later time in your career.
Yeah.
This might be jumping ahead a little bit,
but I'm wondering if how many of the successful people that you talked to had
derailed?
Like is that a common thing that people end up being successful?
I'm glad you asked that.
How many of these successful people derail?
So here's what's interesting.
We get all the speakers coming to Kellogg and I'm sure you get all these
speakers and they tell these up into the right stories,
you know,
and it's just horse shit.
Like people run into career trouble all the time.
And so my whole intent of writing this book,
I mean I'm a VC and a teacher,
this,
this is just the labor of love is I just feel like these conversations aren't
being had enough inside of companies.
The boss should be sitting down with a subordinate and they should be working
together on a development plan that pinpoint some of these areas and unlock
someone's potential by addressing them.
Just doesn't.
It just isn't happening enough.
Talented people run into this stuff all the time.
This is,
this is nothing to be ashamed of.
Having one of these,
you know,
it's like we're human.
We're going to have some weaknesses and some vulnerabilities.
The point is,
and I'll point out this in the next section,
people that do well are on top of their own shit.
They see their own derailment areas.
They see their own vulnerabilities and they either work around them or they find
someone who complements them,
who can help them in area that they're weak.
So don't,
you know,
don't take away by any stretch of the imagination that people that are really
talented don't go through this.
Here's what happened.
I talked to all the people.
I talked to a hundred people who got fired or derailed.
80% of them recovered and those who recovered,
not surprisingly,
we're the ones that accepted the feedback that incorporated that this eye.
This was on me to fix so sad.
Some of the people that I talked to that had gone on and derailed mult like one
guy I talked to three times in a row for the same thing
he kept,
he kept taking the feedback and blaming it on the organization was like this.
My boss was like this and I just was,
my heart went out to him,
but I was a researcher so my job wasn't to play coach.
It was to continue asking me some questions to see what he was doing about this.
And you know,
I don't know if he's going to have an event.
This one particular fellow,
at some point he was going to realize this is on me to fix versus,
you know,
projecting it on somebody else.
You want me to go into the next section?
The next,
I think you're gonna like this next section because it's the,
it's the happy stuff.
Okay.
So this will be a shorter section.
So flipping it on its head and saying people that are considered to be
superstars in their organization,
what do they look like?
Are there any specific behavioral traits or competencies they have that make
them do so well?
So I found out that there's a couple things.
One is they are self aware be they understand their motive structure and then
two they have two specific competencies that matter a lot.
Okay,
so self aware.
What do I mean by that?
They are closer to those who rate them in three sixties if they say on a scale
of one to five there are four in analytical thinking,
the chances are that people reading them say there are four.
Two they don't say there are four nobody else's.
There are two.
They have an accurate self conception.
People with inaccurate self-conception I looked at hundreds of thousands of
three sixties people with inaccurate self conceptions derailed six times more
frequently than those who are accurate in their rating in three sixties wow.
That is based on Korn ferry three 60 research.
Secondly,
they put themselves in the right context because they understand their motives.
So if I asked you what's going in this picture,
what might you say?
Anybody,
what's going on in this picture?
Research.
So let's say you say,
well,
Beth and Joe are working together in a lab and they've worked together five
years.
They have a great working relationship.
They really enjoy working with each other.
You would show an affiliation motive.
That's the lens you're looking at through,
let's say you looked at this picture,
you said App Joe's mansplaning yet again,
there he goes.
That's a power motive.
You're interpreting it in terms of the power dynamic.
Let's say you look at it and said they're this close to solving the Zeke,
the finding the formula for the Zika virus.
That's the achievement motive.
So this guy named David Mcclellan from Harvard said motives or bear because
values are,
values are easier,
values are what's important to you.
So if I asked you what do you value,
you'd probably,
you'd be able to answer it,
maybe give you a minute or two,
but you could probably say,
I value,
uh,
intellectual learning.
I value my family.
Oh yeah.
But if I said,
what,
what drives you?
What are your motives?
It's like,
Ooh,
that's subconscious.
It's trickier.
So to try to get at motives.
Mcclellan did this picture story exercise,
which the hay group has created into a assessment tool where you have to
interpret a bunch of stories,
write down what you see and then a psychologist marks it up and tells you what
your motive profile looks like.
So McClellan says motives are critical because they drive us.
So we want to be in a position that maps to our motive structure and he said
there's an achievement drive.
We have to beat a standard.
I bet a lot of you guys have a high achievement drive.
There is an affiliation motive to be,
have close relationships and love teamwork.
And then there's a power motive to wield influence and enjoy status.
So then I asked the people from the Hay group that worked with Mcclellan,
do different positions,
have different motives,
structures,
and she said,
oh yeah.
I said,
what does a,
what does a corporate CEO look like?
What do you guys think?
What are they gonna look back at our achievement?
Pretty high.
What about affiliation?
Power?
There you go.
What do you think?
I said,
does an entrepreneurial CEO look the same as a corporate CEO?
You're shaking your head.
What do you think?
An entrepreneurial,
see it looks like on
hi,
good job.
Hmm.
Absolutely right.
I said,
what does a good pm look like?
And she's just a hoe.
They're the decathletes pms.
They gotta be good at a lot of stuff.
They've got a big achievement to land the plane.
They've gotta be affiliation to get people that don't report to them to work
well with them.
They've got to be good on power because people that don't report to them got to
cajole them into getting their jobs done too.
They get paid a lot because they're really talented across all three of these
motives.
So I took the test here was a little Carter
super high in achievement drive.
Every picture I interpreted was there accomplishing something high in
affiliation.
So I used,
we allot,
we're doing this,
they're doing this and very,
very low and power.
And so the woman that that,
the psychologist that did my assessment said,
what was it like to be a CEO of a multibillion dollar company?
When you have such low power drive compared to typical CEOs.
And you know what I said,
I didn't like the job.
I was in the wrong job when I was president.
I was back at uh,
in Brisbane,
California,
just down the road here and working with the software developers and working
with the,
or we're developing the product and I loved it.
Then I got promoted to be the CEO and my job was to work with analysts.
It was to deal with klaxons class action lawsuits,
legal issues,
all of a sudden to influence groups of people.
And I would have rather been back working on the product with a team.
So people in there with the right stuff,
they put themselves in the right work context.
They understand their motivators and they under,
and they're self aware about their strengths and weaknesses and vulnerabilities.
So they put themselves in jobs that give them energy.
And I can tell you firsthand that what I do now as a venture capitalist and a
teacher fits my motive structure a lot better than,
see I don't get paid as much,
but it fits my motive.
I'm much happier.
So in the book I list these motives and I added two more after talking to Dan
Pink and doing some more research.
Dan Pink wrote drive.
He says,
Carter,
you got to add autonomy because you know,
wanting to have discretion over your work and you gotta add purpose,
right?
Mission driven.
Some people are just very mission driven.
They want to work in clean tech or they want to work in education or health care
reform.
So in the book I take each of these five motives and here I just gave you a
sample of two but I asked eight questions around each of these areas.
So for example,
I'm very driven by autonomy.
I do my best work when I have freedom to run with my ideas.
I would rather struggle with the answer then be told it,
right?
So if you think that you might question your motives structure in the book,
I have eight questions and each of these five areas to really think about that
might help you understand what's what drives you and is the position you're in
appealing to your motive profile.
Because people with the right stuff,
they put themselves in the right positions to succeed because they naturally
work with,
they have energy because I'm similar to you.
It's like achievement is important to me.
Power risen.
But normally when you see a lot of these things,
they're just together as like,
you know,
getting to the top and be the best.
So achievement is you want your war,
you want to be scored on your work,
you want to be able to see the results in your contribution.
Power is you want to wield influence over others and you enjoy the status.
So if I look at power up here,
I enjoy running clubs in row.
I've never run a damn thing in my life until I was a CEO.
But I mean like in growing up I was never a leader like that.
You know,
it just wasn't something I did.
I was always like swimming or you know,
in club,
you know,
clubs that were about sort of better self betterment.
So they're very different.
They feel like one might lead to the other achievement.
A lot might lead to power,
but the mode of itself is pure in that if you like achievement,
it's really about you wanting to measure yourself against the standard and beat
it.
So here's the last big thought I told you.
There are two competencies that matter a lot.
Okay,
look at this.
So most organizations have what?
10 competencies?
Some of AIDS,
I'm at 12 but the average is 10
if you're only good,
if you're only rated in the top core tile
and managerial effectiveness and build strong relationships,
one competency,
the chances are 12% you're in the 90th percentile of your company and managerial
effectiveness.
If you only have one and it's drive for results.
If that's the only competency you have out of 10
and that's the one you're in the top core tile,
the chances are 14% you're in the 90th percentile in your company and managerial
effectiveness.
But look what happens when you have the two of them.
Build strong relationships and drives for results.
The chances are 72 you don't have to have any of the other eight on average.
If you have those two,
the chances are 72% that you're in the top,
you're the 90th percentile and managerial effectiveness makes sense,
doesn't it?
You build strong relationships.
You build bridges with other departments.
You seek to understand before being understood,
you're empathetic,
you understand the other department's objectives and then they end up
reciprocity.
They end up wanting to help you.
You build bridges and you drive for completion.
If you add to those two,
being self aware so you put yourselves in the right positions,
given your gifts,
that's the right stuff.
That's the formula,
right?
They're so capable.
People derail because they don't have a good of their blind spots and skill gaps
and people with the right stuff seek constant feedback so they can improve and
they're more self aware so they can manage around their inner,
their volt vulnerabilities and put themselves in the right positions given their
strengths.
That's it.
With that we can talk.
Yeah,
so all of them have to question.
Thank you.
All right.
Questions.
Does that surprise you guys to see that you know,
you have all these competencies and that there's only a couple that really,
really matter.
It made me feel better.
Like wow,
really focused on these two areas.
Yeah.
What do you think having gone through this process and written this book,
looking back at your previous career,
you really wish you would've known and your third is in your twenties guy?
That's a good question.
So I will,
can I write on a whiteboard?
Yeah,
go for it.
I can bring it over.
There we go.
Okay.
So this is the back of the brontosaurus.
Let's say you're at a company that's mature.
This is,
this is size of company and this is time.
Okay?
This is the growth stage.
This is the scale stage.
This is a startup phase
and this is the incubate stage.
Okay?
This is probably like where you're getting funding.
You're starting the idea.
So you need to have a certain skill set here,
right?
You've got to have that associational thinking.
You've gotta be,
um,
out in the market and finding the need,
finding the job to be done,
creating the idea.
You have to be optimistic,
you have to be resilient as hell.
Cause everyone says no.
Do you all the time.
You have to be a good salesperson to get people to work with you and to convince
people to loan you money.
Then you start up and all of a sudden you start needing to have some good
selling skills,
some good marketing skills.
You got to raise capital scale.
You got to get processes and procedures in place to be able to scale.
And you have to understand organizational design.
You have to figure out product iteration and product extension here you get to
understand partnerships,
business development,
you're going into international markets.
What's the next version of the product?
How do you keep it alive?
And then boom,
you're talking about complex or you know,
being effective in a complex organization.
Um,
cost management,
how to,
how to re,
uh,
re integrate or reinvigorate a brand.
Like I'm on board of Kellogg Company,
the cereal company.
How do you reinvigorate that brand?
So these stages,
here's what I wish I woulda known.
I played here 11 years at Pepsico,
$50 billion company and I was always butting,
butting up against my own derailment tendencies.
Then I went here to electronic arts when it was 600 million and now it's what,
you know,
it's mark caps like 30 billion.
And I felt much more natural because it was chaotic and it appealed more to my
sort of enjoyment of life,
that speed.
Then I went down here with,
with two guys and start a Blue Nile before it got series a funding.
And I realized that I love this state,
the right in here.
So one thing I wish I would've known is I should've slid down that brontosaurus
sooner and gotten into these environments that are more for me,
better fit my own personality profile.
This was fun.
This was really fun.
This was torturous for me with my personality,
just with my natural mode of structure.
So understanding not only the tech,
not only the industry you want to play in and not only the function you want to
play in,
but where in this,
where in the um,
in the stage of the company do you want to play?
Yeah.
Well I had a question about,
uh,
so knowing that you were the CEO of Walmart and immature part and like thinking
it wasn't for you,
when did you know that and,
and like what was your strategy there specifically?
Something happened.
So I went to Walmart,
so I went to blue,
we did Blue Nile,
then I went to Walmart when it was here.
We were 30 of US starting it and it was crazy and we made a bunch of mistakes
and it was chaotic and it's fun.
And then we got up into here and I was a CEO and then they wanted to move me to
be this,
to,
to get trained under someone,
to be the CEO for a Sam's Club.
That was my next move and I had a good review
and I drove home.
I had a condo in Bentonville and lived out here and I drove back and I realized
I don't have any energy right now.
What's going on?
Why am I not thrilled with this big opportunity?
And I realized that I didn't have,
I didn't think of it in terms of motive structure like I just talked about
today.
It something was not right for me.
And it was because I would have been playing up in here again at Sam's club and
I liked playing in here.
So what I did naturally was I left the company and I went back to another early
stage,
start up again.
So you know,
the,
and I'm not,
I'm not saying anything about evaluative,
about being in a mature company.
It wasn't right for me given my personality.
That's what I'm saying.
Not that this is,
there's many wonderful jobs up here.
I just wasn't for me.
I think we have time for one more question
now.
One more.
Um,
you talk a lot about just like personal skills and things like that,
but then,
then you talked about how your reactions were with different managers.
So how important do you think having an effective and strong manager is in kind
of career growth and being able to,
you know,
correct yourself as well?
Yeah,
I was,
I think I can tell you the guy's name was Steven Quinn,
the Canadian that say,
I mean I,
I brought him to Walmart once I got to Walmart he became the chief marketing
officer of Walmart cause he saw what it was such a wonderful manager.
He saved my career so I,
it's so important I can hardly express it.
Let's say you have a bad one though.
Let's say you're under somebody who's ineffective.
Are there a captain,
fantastic and they don't give,
it's really important,
you know,
people say,
well it's important to have a mentor.
It's important to have,
I don't think of it as one mentor.
I think of it as you want to plug into smart people,
different places of your organization to learn from them,
but also to have safe haven if you need it.
I was out in a job out here.
I drove,
I had to drive to Pleasanton every day before the bark came through and I was
under a boss that was ineffective and I ended up finding safe haven for,
uh,
somebody who had been,
informal mentor.
I said,
this isn't working out and he goes,
come join my group.
So I think what you want to do is you want to have multiple people you can count
on,
not like one Obi wan Kenobi mentor,
but like a bunch of people in different departments that you can say,
Hey,
can I buy a cup of coffee and can you help me reason through this problem I'm
facing?
And because the chances are pretty good,
you'll find safe haven with somebody when there's a,
or a reorg or something and you'll be able to take advantage of that,
that relationship.
And it's actually fulfilling for them too.
It's tough,
smart person.
Like you would want me,
you know,
you'd seek me out for my advice.
So I don't,
I wouldn't hesitate.
I think when people put this moniker of mentor,
it sounds so heavy.
Like there's this obligation.
I don't think of it that way.
I think of having like five or six different counselors that you can just go to
now and again.
Yeah.
Great.
So I think we're out of time.
Thank you so much.
Thank you guys.